stay in your lane and start like hack hard okay don't listen to all of the chatter about oh you
know justin's got 50 bugs on this app no ignore that pick your portion of the scope lock in and
find a ton of books best part of hacking when you can just you know critical thing right
sup hackers uh super lightweight this week in bug bounty segment for this week we just have
a new program announcement on yes we hack and that is going to be decathlon um and so if any of you
guys are uh you know outdoorsy type you're probably familiar with this brand they just went public on
yes we hack and of course yes we hack doesn't do vdps so this is of course a bug bounty program
um and you know like we always talk about maybe a good idea to hack brands you're familiar with or
that you've used so if you're uh if you're using any of their their equipment then it could be cool
to check out they've got www in scope for all of their um tlds across all the different languages
so check them out if you're interested in uh popping that that brand all right let's go back to the show
all righty sup hackers this week uh rezo and i are both going on vacation so we're doing a little bit
of a separate pre-record and i've got an episode for you guys on how to succeed at live hacking events
that's been one of my things that i focused on and my career is about bounty hunter is how do you
perform consistently at these live hacking events because the opportunities are amazing and i want
to continue going to them so recently i was working with one of my mentees grep me the guy that runs
the hacker notes for critical thinking and um i sat down with him during one of our sessions as he was
going into his first live hacking event and gave him some advice on uh how how to succeed at the life
acumen and my boy crushed it guys my boy crushed it and uh i've selfishly of course i'm going to take
credit for that no um brandon worked really hard and uh and did a great job but i did want to take some
of the advice that i gave him and consolidate it into an episode for you guys so that if any of you guys
have the opportunity to go to a live hacking event um you know how to crush it and also i think a lot
of these principles are really applicable to uh just how to hack in general with intensity so um
we'll kind of go through those but first let's go ahead and jump into some of the uh just research
news that's kind of hit the scene over the past couple days i'm gonna go ahead and share my screen
the first one that's up is uh yet another post from jorian um this guy has been crushing it uh with
research lately and this one sort of uh piggybacks off of uh paulo's uh research uh on double click
jacking um and and i think makes it makes it quite good um the title of this one is the ultimate
double click jacking poc for those of you on youtube i'm sharing my screen um and it's it's just
a combination of a lot of different factors and stuff we've talked about on the podcast so i wanted
to go ahead and show it uh i'm gonna actually play the the poc video here while i'm talking about
it so you guys can see on youtube um really really well done essentially this technique
sort of combines uh the research of double click jacking along with uh window.move2 to to hijack
the click um and a pop under that we've talked about from a couple weeks back from renwa um using
the sign in with google uh functionality that's sort of embedded into chrome to cause a pop-up to get
pushed behind a window and then he simulates it with a flappy birds uh game where you know your click
click click click to make the bird jump and then when you need to make him jump high of course you
double click and that's when uh your git lab account gets pwned um so really really awesome poc here by
jorian if you guys want to if you guys ever had the opportunity to build out something like this uh then
this could be a great place to start um taking a look at that um the the explanation here is very
thorough you can see exactly how everything works with the with the move to um that's why he uses the
pop under is to you know get everything in place uh and ready for when you need to hijack the click
um and just really really good work and also shout out to renwa for the um for the pop under um yeah and he
also builds out like the fake cloud flare captcha it was it was pretty clean definitely a good read if
you're into client side stuff um okay so next up is uh the grafana cves that hit recently um and i am a
little bit of a grafana hacker myself so whenever something grafana comes up i kind of like to go back
and look at it i think grafana is a really cool code base where uh you know it's written in go it's pretty readable um you
can go in and you can go in you can go and audit the code and kind of attack it and grafana is pretty
much everywhere like there are hundreds of instances of grafana uh if not more out there um in in scope
of bug bounty programs so it's a really good target for if you're trying to find um zero days in a
software and then spray it across a bunch of bug bounty programs it's a really good target so this guy alvaro um
goes ahead and documents uh some of the uh vulnerabilities he found um and we see that
it starts with an open redirect he kind of goes through um exactly how he did that by getting
a uh specific um file embedded and then he hits it eventually he hits it with
a um where's that where's that piece right here so here's the open redirect right here it's via a
slash and then backslash base traversal right um which is something that we see or uh quite often so
this turns into right here this turns into a absolute url when normalized by the browser so
slash backslash at the beginning will turn into slash slash which is an absolute url not a relative
this this uh sort of relative url and absolute url confusion happens really often and this is one of the more
uh common variations i see so great work to finding the open redirect and then he he changed that
changed that into full read ssrf by hitting the render endpoint on grafana um and he's able to do
lots of other stuff with it as well some client side path traversal um so it's just a good a good
summary of how exactly to chain an open redirect inside of these uh environments and he gets uh 3700 for
it um he does say however that uh this one isn't really uh great for spraying to multiple bug bounty
programs since the exploitation paths require authentication but to be honest i would also just
i would send it out just in case you know if you can build a poc and you're very confident that your poc
will work if somebody authenticated clicks on it then um yeah why not but there could be some nuance to
the situation here anyway it's a good read maybe check out grafana if you're interested in doing some
zero-day research on an open source project that also has big bug bounty implications
um oh also yeah he dropped the uh exploit as well we'll link it in the description but he dropped the
exploit for that on github as well on his uh on his github uh cve 2025 4123 so you can check that
out there all right last last piece on the news is evan connelly's write-up um on his first 100 bugs that
he found uh on hacker one um and i just love these sort of data like reports right like these where
people take all their reports they inglomerate all the data together they sort it by type they talk
about their strengths and weaknesses as a hacker um i just think this is a really profitable read for
anybody who's into bug bounty it doesn't even necessarily have to be the beginners though certainly
this is uh very impactful for beginners so if you guys have any friends that are getting into bug bounty or
something like that might be a good one to forward over to them and uh and let's see if i can find the
um the quote that i really wanted to talk about here um yeah he says that moment made everything
click for me not just the adrenaline of finding a critical but the realization that you can uncover
impactful issues even outside of the typical web uh proxy tool flow right and uh this single report
gave me the confidence to treat other programs as viable targets and and i think for a lot of uh hackers
especially if you guys are mentoring newer hackers it's really um it's really impactful to try to show
them and make them believe tangibly that bugs exist that's why i like to do you know with my friends
that i'm teaching how to hack um i like to do these these hack alongs where we have i have a vuln
uncovered already like a low or something like that on one of these programs and then i guide them
to finding it during the hacking session and sometimes i don't have time to prep that in advance but
um i've done it once or twice where i have and uh it's it's just great to see the click in their in
their in their brain like oh yeah wow i just found a security vulnerability i can hack this um so
cool ideas there to implement with your friends if you're interested
um and it costs a couple hundred bucks right you know you're gonna lose the low or whatever but
it it adds a lot more value to your friends so it's worth it for me i love these graphs here talking
about the severity distribution the type distribution and of course i love the shout
out that he gives us at the end saying check out the critical thinking podcast and discord community
dude evelyn i appreciate you man thank you so much for being an active part of our community
um and i also do echo what he says here about uh reddit bug bounties r slash bug bounty reddit
uh it's there's a lot of jaded people out there and you know i can't blame them in in some capacity
because it is very much a punch in the gut when you try to submit something to bug bounty and a triager
says you know f off or whatever and you just can't get a bug um or you get dupe right on a perfectly
valid bug super annoying and and i can see people get jaded and not have the um you know the gumption
the stick-to-it-ness to keep pushing pushing pushing um but that's what we try to talk about here on the
pot right we try to show you that consistent and high quality success like evan's here in the bugdani
world is totally possible if you just keep pushing pushing pushing and understand the rules of the
game um and and keep keep giving it your full effort so anyway great great write up by evan definitely
check it out uh and pass it on to some newer hackers as well um love this section advice for
newer hackers as well okay so that's the news let's go ahead and move over to um the main topic of today's
episode which is how to win at live hacking events now i'll just spend a moment giving some of my
credentials for this um i have won four live hacking events two hacker one events two uh google events
um and freaking franz rosen keeps uh one-upping me so i think there are a couple people i don't hold the
top um spot for most live hacking events one uh but i've done this a couple times and i participated in
probably 30 plus live hacking events um and so i do have a little bit of a system here for how to
how to win at these how to perform well at least and and also let me say i have like eight second
place trophies like uh which is super annoying to me uh but you know my goal is consistently to try to
rank in the top five if if i'm in the top 10 i'm not going to be sad uh but if i'm below the top 10
i'm like i hacked something up i gotta figure out what i did wrong so um let me take some of the
pieces of the methodology that i've developed over the years and give it to you guys
okay so i'm going to break this out into several sections first is going to be pre-event then we're
going to move into scope call or post scope call we're going to move to the uh dupe window uh end
which is a sign is a big change in how you should approach the targets the on-site and the day of
the event um so let's go ahead and go through each one of these so first pre-event you get your invite
um typically through the hacker one panel or an email or something like that
um and you've got a timeline now and you don't typically know the target at this point um but you know
maybe sometimes you hear through the grapevine what the target's going to be a lot of people will go
and start trying to hack on that target and become familiar with that target and come with
bugs in their pocket to the live hacking man i personally don't do this because i think it's a
high risk thing to do um i prefer to focus on you know the ways to optimize my earnings and i don't
think that spending time on this target you know before i know what's in scope or what's not in scope
is probably the best way to optimize my earnings so i don't do that but be aware that some people may do
that and that you know people may have a critical on an in scope asset in their pocket on days day one
you know as soon as the scope call is over um so you know weigh your options there if you really
really want to perform at this event and it's like your your life goal and you're not really optimizing
for money you're optimizing for this then you may want to start you know try to put some feelers out
see if anybody knows the target and then uh start pre-hacking if they have a bug bounty program where
stuff is in scope um okay here's where stuff gets a little bit controversial okay i am going to
recommend uh or my i'm not even going to recommend it i'm going to tell you guys that my approach
is not to collab before the the dupe window ends okay and the reason for that is because i think that
uh i find a lot of bugs before the dupe window ends and if i am splitting those with other hackers
uh then it doesn't normally work out in my in my favor from a financial perspective and i've tried
this many many different ways many many different times it just doesn't typically work out in my in
my favor so what i typically do is i lock in for the between when the event starts and when the dupe
window ends i should back up what is the dupe window the dupe window is a period of time after the
uh live hacking event starts where if people dupe on each other the reward gets split across all the
hackers okay um and if you are collaborating with other hackers right then you're you get us
in in that report is duped then you get a split of a split and these things get really really small
really really fast which is very demoralizing so um i personally don't collab before the dupe window
ends um there are people that very successfully do this and they are can they are very invested
all of the people on the team are very invested in spending the same amount of time hacking right
working very hard um and my advice to people that would be willing to do full split collabs with
other hackers from the very beginning is collab with a hacker you feel inferior to or or a hacker that
has a very different skill set than you right um that way you're not going to feel like there's some
sort of um overlap there or or if somebody is not as invested with you as you you're not going to feel
like oh i put you know 40 hours into this while they put 20 i'm getting i'm getting gypped out of
the situation okay and at the end of the day if you do commit to a collab commit to the collab and don't
don't take a ledger you know but you you should use it to inform future decisions but don't hold it
against the other collaborators does that make sense hopefully so all right uh so i personally don't
collab before the dupe window two uh lock in okay i i always say this to people if this if you're
doing a live hacking event you should take it very seriously um when i had a job a w2 job i would take
time off of work unpaid because i'm going to make more money at that this than i am at my work anyway
um and get really serious about it uh what does it mean to get serious about it well what i often do is
preload time with my wife with my kids with my chores right i try to you know take my wife out
on a couple dates make sure her her love meter is at 10 out of 10 right going into this because i'm
going to be really focused on work for the next couple weeks same thing with the kids make sure
you do something fun with them make sure that they you know know that you care about them so that you
are when you're locked in here they're not running on zero you know in their tank um and then try to
knock out any chores or logistic things that might get in the way you know if you if you've got you
need if the lawn needs to be cut cut it um if you need to do your taxes get them knocked out before
the live hacking event so that you can stay locked in and not be distracted by other things
um during that time okay and here's another one that is really important guys one of the very um
impactful things about the live hacking event is how competitive it is right i would strongly
recommend to you not to look at the leaderboard do not look at the stats near the bounty brief do not
pay attention to the hackers in the slack that are like excuse me could i get a could i get a triage
on you know number one two three or whatever because it's a critical and i really want you to get it
done quick because your users are at risk they're just flexing dude they're flexing okay and that's
going to do nothing but make you feel bad about your findings if you haven't had a critical okay so
uh don't do that stay in your lane and start like hack hard okay don't listen to all of the chatter
about oh you know justin's got 50 bugs on this app no ignore that pick your portion of the scope lock in
and find a shit ton of bugs okay also inversely don't flex on other hackers okay if you do find a
crit don't be that guy that like puts it in the channel and it's like hey guys i got a crit on this
one could you get a fast you know no just be sportsman like lock in hack stuff present yourself
with humility okay um okay so that's sort of pre-event stuff i guess the ignoring the other hackers is
kind of after the event starts but i could i'll move that to my next section let's talk about the
scope call okay what the scope call is the kickoff call that occurs when you are starting the live
hacking event there will typically be a period of time where um you know they'll do a presentation
they'll talk about the bonuses they'll talk about the increased rewards they'll talk about the scope
right for the event what what targets you can uh hack on they'll give you access to like accounts
uh that sort of thing um yeah what i would recommend to you here is focus on two things for the scope call
what does the team want me to hack on what is going to make them go oh shit if i if i pop that
right that's what you should probably be hacking on however you need to balance that a little bit with
anticipated interest from other hackers because it does suck when you get a bunch of dupes so what i
typically go for is something that is tier zero right so something that is extremely valuable to the
program but probably like tier one or tier two on interest with other hackers right other hackers are
maybe a little intimidated by it or maybe don't think it's as feature rich as it could be something
like that right um i don't typically go for tier zero interest zero because that's going to get a lot of
a lot of uh other um interest from other hackers um all right then the next thing that i'd recommend
is something that i call pick your portion okay so look at the scope that they presented to you
and you got it you got to pick you know what piece of that app you want to cover or what piece
of this this company you want to cover because typically the scope is going to be pretty wide
and you're not going to be able to cover all of it with enough depth that's just the way these things
work okay um so what i typically do is i pick one app and i say all right i'm going to go ham on this
app for the next like couple days um and as soon as the the the scope call is over make a snap decision
on what that is and try to go try all of the impactful semi-obvious scenarios over the past
or over the next like couple hours like you know the one that pops in my mind is freaking
host header based uh password reset link injection right where you change the host header that host
header gets put into a password reset link that was generated and it goes into someone's email and now
you've got account takeover you know zero click or technically maybe one click ato um try all that
stuff for the first uh you know couple hours because you want to try to pop those as early as possible
um yeah and then after those couple hours you should you know just from the feel of the app
when you're in there trying all those other things you should have an idea on whether your snap decision
was a valid decision or not on on like is there enough scope here for me to focus on it for like
four to five days at least um you know maybe 10 hours a day uh or do i need to switch to something else
you have one opportunity here to switch to another piece of scope okay once you switch you must stick
to that scope do not get distracted by the shiny objects okay stay locked in on that piece of scope
until you are the world expert on that piece of scope i typically recommend three times as long as you
would normally spend on an app to spend on these apps that you're in the live hacking it's here because
you need to go deep you need to go deep deep deep on these apps okay um so that's kind of what i would
recommend um let me see what i had something else under this section uh yeah like i said try to pick
something that other hackers might be uh intimidated by and then uh prioritize what attack vectors you
implement based off of the attack vector value that i've talked about in my high roi bug hunters talk
if you haven't seen that it's available to the critical thinkers in the critical thinking discord
and i think there might be a recording floating around there on youtube uh no that was bug bounty village
uh not the main uh main stage so it was not recorded so the only recording is in is in the critical
thing first here i said well i'll just give you a summary of it real quick the attack vector value
is um well hold on let me let me just pause it really quick and grab the the presentation
okay here's the one slide from from that i'm going to share from this which is uh the attack vector
value okay this is what i typically uh use to try to decide what i'm going after this is the impact
and this attack vector value is is um defined by the following function it's impact times viability
divided by friction okay and this isn't perfect this is just how i think about it currently so impact would
be what is like the the the impact of a successful exploitation right like do i get account takeover
do i get like can i leak the you know query parameters i don't know like there's a large variety
of of impact that could happen and then what is the viability uh what is the chance that this will
actually work or not right if if something about the application informs us that wow they're super
vulnerable to idor and i can see a you know a request that it looks like it's vulnerable to idor but it's
like super buried in the application or something like that the liability is pretty high that that will
actually work right because we know that they're vulnerable to idor pretty regularly we just got to
get deep into the app to to get it and speaking of getting deep into the app that's what friction is
right so friction is the amount of effort to uh attempt to give an attack vector um so impact times
viability divided by friction okay and that's kind of how i think about these attack vectors and don't
don't get me wrong i'm not like quantifying each attack vector idea that i come up with i'm kind of
doing this vibe vibe mostly in my brain um but it would be really cool to figure out a way to quantify
all these so maybe something for you guys to think on all right let me get back to my other stuff um
yeah so prioritize off of those three variables impact um you know viability and friction
okay now here's where stuff gets a little bit uh counterintuitive okay um during the live hacking
event you may be uh inclined especially if you're super locked in to not eat not drink not exercise
not get any sunshine not get any sleep right i'm looking at you ronnie carta mr lupin over there mr
all-nighter um i would really not recommend this your brain will not be functioning at top capacity and
you can say oh i'm one of those people where no you're not like that's just not how human biology works
but it it doesn't um so really try to get good quality food try to get water get in some some
exercise in sunshine you're gonna your brain will be functioning better and get however much sleep
you need okay you know there is variance in how much sleep people need but you do need some sleep
i guarantee that so um don't neglect those things i am not a perfect example of this i do not feed myself
during live hacking events my wife very graciously will bring me food while i'm hacking because i i
just for some reason for the life of me cannot remember to eat or drink while i'm hacking um
but we have a system for that right my wife and i partner on that and um and she helps with that as
far as exercise and sunshine goes i go for walks and that's something i'll kind of cover in a little bit
but you need to take time away well we can just cover it now you need to take time away from the
screen and away from stimulation to let your brain sort of iterate i often will go into the hot tub or
go for a walk for those two things to let my brain start try to um come up with different attack vectors
or different ways of approaching a problem i have popped multiple crits while sitting in the hot tub
or on a walk so it's very very important especially ones that i spent like eight hours staring at my
screen for i was so frustrated about this one time like i knew that this one vulnerability was exploitable
and i just stared at my screen for eight hours and i was like you know really honestly barely doing
any typing or or or reading i was just mostly like thinking but i couldn't figure it out and
then i go in the hot tub and i solve it in like 30 minutes so so it really try different environments
try to get some exercise try to get some sunshine okay um yeah and and then i also say don't forget to
relax a little bit during these events if you're taking my advice you're probably going really hard
but you need to have some scheduled calculated rest as well okay i i do this typically on sunday i try to
try to follow uh the christian biblical principles of sabbath um during the live hacking events there
is some nuance to that but i do try to spend a bit of time on those sundays relaxing and you know
detentionizing myself um okay now i'm going to give you a little bit of conflicting advice with that
if there is something that pulls you away from hacking have your brain running on that hacking
stuff while you're away if you're in the shower if you're on the toilet if you're running an errand
you know be thinking about the app think about attack vector ideation have a notebook llm or
whatever read you the docs right if you're out somewhere if you're waiting like at a doctor's
appointment or in line at the grocery store scroll through the docs read the docs you know you you
need to really you know eat and breathe and sleep on this application for the next uh week or so um
and then while you're doing this record attack vector ideas record gadgets um you know i do it on
like one of these big i've got a bunch of them right here but they've got text on them so i'm not
going to hold them up but these big like legal pads these yellow legal pads that just helps me think
even though my handwriting is atrocious so have something with you where you can write that down
um okay here's another thing you need to realize if you want to win this live hacking event you need
to find at least one critical so one of the mistakes i've made in the past that i noted down for myself
was i wanted volume and coverage but i didn't go after high high attack vector um targets enough okay so
there was one app or one event in particular i'm thinking of not going to disclose the company but
every single freaking endpoint on this company was vulnerable so i was like all right i'm gonna cover
all of these and it ate up all my time um and i got like 40 mediums but i didn't win that event because
i didn't get enough criticals i came in second hmm hurts me um so don't make that same mistake i did
make sure you're going for high impact bugs at these live hacking events because that's really one of the
differentiators okay that being said once you've picked your portion you must cover all the core
functionality dig through the js files configure the app do whatever you have to do to become the world
expert on this do not neglect off that is one thing that i have kind of done in the past okay do not
neglect the authentication mechanisms we spend a lot of time um checking authorization most of the time
as hackers but authentication is sometimes a little bit scary don't neglect it assess it
um and then more than ever and once again i know that this is in juxtaposition with what i just said
about finding criticals but you need to double down on any weaknesses you found and that's what i thought
i was doing in that live hacking event right i said oh wow every vulnerable every endpoint is vulnerable
to idor i'm going to report every single idor um and you should definitely do that but you also can't
do that to the neglect of high impact vulnerabilities uh you know not to say that those are mutually exclusive
but you know what i'm saying um double down on any weaknesses you find spend time thinking why was
this specific endpoint vulnerable why why is this application acting so quirky in this specific scenario right
you got to think through all those things okay once you've really like covered all the main functionality
of your your portion that you picked then you go deep into peripheral assets sdks legacy stuff staging
assets mobile apps chrome extensions apis you know xml based garbage you know like everything that
you can find on this app and and do some like past recon on this app too to understand like what the app
looked like as it evolved over time go deep deep deep into those okay and then so uh the last section
that i had here while we were in um the actual like scope post scope call pre-dupe window end portion was
just a quick shout out to joseph's uh recent write-up that that we'll put in the description uh root for your
friends right if you're if you are working with people you know even if you're working not not
collabing with them but you're like in the live hack you met with them like root for them as much as
you can like i said try to try to not give yourself the input especially if you're hyper competitive and
tend to get down on yourself if you're not performing as well try not give yourself input on how other
hackers are doing but if you see it push your brain to respond positively like hell yeah my boy joseph just
popped a crit let's go you know that sort of thing right rather than like oh man i don't have a crit
you know what am i gonna do no root for your friends take that as motivation okay um now you
know that there's a crit out there right you can go find it too okay things change a little bit when
when the dupe window ends this is typically like a week or so um i don't know the actual duration i'm just
normally like all right set a calendar entry go um but when the dupe window ends you know
things change a little bit i typically open myself up to collaboration a little bit more i try
i try to finish most of my stuff by the time the dupe the dupe period ends and i submit most everything
that that i have you know especially if i'm unfamiliar with a company's threat model and
what they may or may not consider a vulnerability you don't really get nas at live hacking events so
submit what you've got and you know they may inform it of you and it's not the end of the world
you know um if you're at a live hacking event you've probably got enough rep and stuff where your
signal in or impact or whatever can take a little bit of a hit okay so don't stress out about that
um yeah so you know if for whatever reason i wasn't able to like exploit some gadgets or um maybe i've
got like half vulnerabilities that are just very close to being exploitable that's when you kind of
reach out to some other hackers and kind of get a feel for what's going on you see what kind of success
they've had on what um other pieces of scope you see uh you try to compare notes you try to give add
value to the other hacker by like hey here's this vulnerability like does this is my takeaway from
this vulnerability right you're trying to add value to other hackers at that point okay um and and
also want to say trade value right if somebody comes to you and says hey man you know i know you're
looking at this scope i figured out how to like decrypt this really important thing dude thank you so
much like hold on let me grab something for you you know get them a you know an equivalent trade of
value as far as information goes in the live hacking event which was my little circle light is off there
my bad um yeah so try to get them an equivalent trade of value right um so that you are adding value
to your other hackers as well um pay very close attention to what you missed man i'll never forget this
one live hacking event where freaking inhibitor 181 and i spent the entire event on the same scope and
didn't have almost any overlapping vulnerabilities crazy and i just the stuff that i missed and he way
out hacked me at that event like crazy um the stuff that i missed i will never ever ever ever ever miss
because of the pain in my heart from what he found right um and that that pain can help you learn right
but you got to also redirect that in a positive way like you know dab up your boy be like yo
well done dude you know that sort of thing um all right uh let's see yeah find hackers who have
hacked on similar scope and compare notes that's kind of what i was saying there also um i'll add this
piece try to collaborate fairly uh in this in this post um dupe window collaboration stuff now now i
open myself up to collaboration you want to you want to if someone if somebody gave you something
you want to offer them at least you know five or ten percent right of the vulnerability that's a
minimum if somebody if somebody um but you really want do want to be fair a lot of people will be like
oh man if you even give this little bit then it's 50 50 and i'm like i don't think so i
i don't think that's the best way to deal with this right it doesn't feel great from my side when
i do that to other people and it doesn't feel great when i'm on the on the the giving side of
that either so i i try to say hey here's the number i really value honesty give me your thoughts
you know and we're all professionals here we can negotiate um and then what i would ask is that you
advocate for yourself fairly and honestly and i'm not going to take it personally right that's what we
that's what we do and then at the end of the day you know if there is conflict know that your
relationship with the other hacker is more valuable than the specific bounty because if you're going
to be on the live hacking event scene uh that hacker will definitely have something you need at some
point and uh the you know you don't want to burn that bridge also just don't be a bad person
that too okay cool all right so that's kind of like the post-dupe window collaboration there's not
much actually that happens after the uh dupe window closes besides you know more collaboration
um and you know things start getting triaged which is cool um but you're really you stay locked in you
know if you have fully covered your target and you have um you know 3x to the time that you would spend on
that target then switch to a different target and do that same methodology right um or maybe a peripheral
target right something that is tangentially related to the application you're already hacking so you can
reuse some of that knowledge okay next section is on site so um some of you guys may not be
participating in an on-site live hacking event but it is very very tricky to stay locked in when you
are on site because your friends are around you're meeting people for the first time you're surrounded
by hackers that are of similar skill level and you're and it's freaking great like that is why we made
the joel and i started this podcast way back in 2023 was because we freaking love that environment and we
want to bring some of that hype and energy to you guys every single week okay um that being said if
you really want to win and you really want to perform you should stay locked in on site a lot of people
you arrive you know you do the meet and greet or whatever and then people will just like drop their
laptops and go out drinking and party and then stay up till three and get super drunk and be hung over the
next day and it just like it it cascades those people are can do whatever they want no judgment
here but if you want to win don't do that yeah and i think if you want to win you or if you really
are passionate about hacking it's really fun to just grab your laptop and grab a soda or whatever
and go back to your room with your buddies and be like i'm looking at this what are you looking at
comparing nodes hacking on stuff together almost every single event if you do this you will pop a crit
in the hotel room like it just happens that way my boy nagli has done it like 10 live hacking events in
a row um shout out to my boy not like uh so stay locked in there will be more time to play after the
live hacking event is over okay um and you want to kind of optimize your time on site by utilizing your
other hackers that are present right so if you know your buddy's really good at this and you've got a
lead in that area maybe just connect him with that lead even though if you think that maybe there's some
more time that you could spend on it um and plus it feels good to get momentum going right and the life
hack in the on-site live hacking events um so definitely do that if you have no leads between
you and other hackers which is pretty rare but i have seen it a couple times pick a small small piece
of scope to deep dive and try to finish it all you know during the on-site period okay um this i've done
this a couple times and it has paid out uh for me pretty well um the other thing is you can do is if
there's a meet and greet and the the team is actually there that you're hacking you can go up
and talk to them and be like hey guys listen um i just kind of finished the scope that i was hacking on
if you were in my shoes where would you look for vulnerability and i did this one time i had not
hacked on this target at all i did this on the day of the life hacking event one of the one of the
engineers came up to me he's like dude this area is riddled with bugs go tear it up and i did exactly
what he said and made like 40 grand um so shout out to that guy i don't know if you remember who you
are this is a long time ago but shout out to that guy dude because uh that was amazing and there goes
all my student loans um so that that is also a a thing to do talk to the team and also pivoting into
the day of the event sort of section when you're on site you know on the event on the event day talk
to the triagers advocate for your bugs okay a lot of people are not doing that when you get on on site
if there is a bug that's mistriaged or if there is a you know high or critical vulnerability that you've
got in there that is not getting the attention that it deserves um go like knock on the war room door
and be like hey man here's this and have a prepared poc have a you know very easy to follow um flow that
they can see to quickly reproduce the bug and triage it um and that helps them because they don't have to
like get all the context on that bug and you know do it they can just see it and follow along with you
and it helps you because now your bug is triaged and you know on the in the payout queue for the live
hacking event on the day of so and if something is mistriaged then definitely go and knock on the door
and be like yo yo this is hacked this is not a low this is a high you know this is a crit um and and so
advocate for your bugs um if you literally cannot do this find a friend to do it i have advocated for
my friends bugs multiple times on their behalf um because i don't know if you guys know this but i can
talk a little bit right you know just a tiny bit um so uh find someone else to do it for you as well
once again i'll repeat it stay locked in on the day of the live hacking event sit down hack hack hack
till the last minute on the timer okay uh one of the bugs that i am most proud of i the ever i
completed the exploit for and demoed it for a team of eight eight team members right there were the
program we were hacking on live within the last hour of the event i'm so happy i popped that bug to this
day and one of my favorite hacking memories ever is me sitting in this environment having 18 members
from this massive company behind me and be like check this out boom and it's like a mega crit and
they're all like oh shit like you know it was just it was the best it was it was the best guys stay
locked in you will find cool stuff at the live hacking event okay day of the event last thing pay very
close attention to show and tell um i'm sorry not last thing but close last thing pay very close
attention to show and tell show and tell is the portion where um you know other hackers will give
a presentation on the bugs that they found that the team selected because they thought they were the
coolest truly reflect on these bugs and figure out how you could have found them yourself okay and then
really integrate that into your methodology visualize yourself doing that right and that's how you improve
the other thing is you know show and tell bugs are great but guess what you have access to unlimited
show and tell if you go around and you talk to other hackers and be like hey can you show me your
bugs and i'll show you mine show me yours and i'll show you mine um and to be honest i've learned so
much from that and most everybody at that live hack event is passionate and loves hacking right so very
rarely will they be like nah i'm not going to do it there are a couple hackers that will be like nah i want to
keep my secrets to myself but most everybody's like dude check this one out and they show you one that's
really amazing and blow you know blows your mind and then you know they get that dopamine hit of having
somebody who also understands how impactful these vulnerabilities are be like dude no way and then
and then you know you get the the knowledge and it's just it's a win-win so talk to other hackers uh
freaking brandon grabbed me that i mentioned at the beginning of this does an amazing job of this
phenomenal job and it just makes the growth just skyrocket as a hacker
um okay last little bit um before i close it out i know it's already getting long especially for a
solo episode um this is something that's very near and dear to my heart do not define your identity as
a hacker on the outcome of this live hacking event okay if you showed up to this live hacking event you
followed what i said here you gave it 110 and you did not rank or you didn't find a bug that's okay
all right it happens it if you follow this methodology i think it's probably pretty rare
but i i'll tell you i have had really really bad live hacking events with like sub 10 bugs uh and
it just happens nothing you can do about it doesn't mean you're the worst hacker doesn't mean that you
don't deserve to be there right and if you if you are if you are defining your identity as a hacker on
the outcome of live hacking event it's so volatile dude it's so volatile you could have just picked the
wrong piece of scope the asset could be 503 while you're trying to hack it and it's just you know there's
so many confounding variables that could go into place okay put your identity as a person and as a
hacker you know in something more stable than live hacking events or even bug bounties in general because
bug bounties are hella unstable i've said this time and time again i personally really really struggled
with this until my wife and i had a conversation about hey justin you're not putting your identity in
christ which is where i i normally try to focus my identity on right um as a christian and after that
conversation with my wife i have almost never struggled with that comparison that burnout um i just
felt much more free to enjoy my hacking life when my identity is in christ rather than in my performance
as a hacker right and i'm not going to get all religious on you guys you guys can you know maybe
christianity isn't the religion for you maybe and you've got something else right whatever but just
don't freaking put it in bug bounty please like bug bounty is volatile as hell so uh yeah that's my
recommendation to you put your identity in something more stable um all right guys i think that's about
it you know if you if you follow all these i think you will have a really really solid uh live hacking
event um and like i said many of these principles are applicable to outside of the life hacking event as
well just normal bug bounty right reflecting on the documentation um you know staying locked in going
really hard making sure you're taking care of your responsibility so that you can optimize your longer
pieces of time as uh for for bug bounty and staying locked in on technically complex stuff um so there's
lots of little tidbits there that you can use um to optimize your your experience in normal bug bounty as
well um just just right before this episode there was a little bit of discussion in the critical
thinking discord about uh rating the show on apple podcast and spotify which is something that i used
to ask you guys to do every every time but i i just kind of forgot now that we've gotten a couple
hundred of them and and we're pretty well ranked so but i'll ask now if you guys enjoyed the show please
give a rating on apple podcast and spotify if you're listening on youtube sub on youtube drop a comment
for us that does help the show get some additional distribution um and of course if you're not in the
critical thinking discord definitely go check it out um it's a really solid community as uh as evan said in
his write-up that we covered earlier on um and i'm to be honest man i'm really blown away by it i'm
really grateful to be in the critical thinking community because there are a lot of um people
there that are are way more skilled than i am contributing and adding value and i'm just like wow
this is freaking great so um i would love to see you there if you have if you haven't seen you know
how to get in there you can go to ctbb.show click the discord link or ctv.show discord if you want to
just go directly to it um all right i think that's a wrap hope you guys enjoy this episode and i'll see
you next week peace and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for
watching to the end y'all if you want more critical thinking content uh or if you want to support the show
head over to ctvb.show discord you can hop in the community there's lots of great high level hacking
discussion happening there on top of master classes hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time
hunters guild if you're a full-time hunter it's a great time trust me all right i'll see you there